uh we do have an update for you on that
ukrainian-born las vegas orchestra
conductor we told you about last week so
even as terrascrisa was conducting the
las vegas sinfoniata concert over the
weekend at the clark county library in
flamingo
his heart was aching for his family and
friends
the life we know as we go to school we
go to teach we go to rehearsals we go to
bank to go to restaurant it it doesn't
exist there it's normalcy they still
have a
electricity
and water and it's considered okay we're
facing humanitarian crisis i cannot i
it's all
it's impossible because we were okay
here
emotions ran high on both sides of the
stage my thanks to taraskrisa and the
las vegas synthetic for inviting me to
be part of that concert it was quite an
experience now if you would like to
contribute to the ukraine relief effort
look for links in the online version of
this story on our website 8newsnow.com
it was very emotional there on this
concert on sunday afternoon at the clark
county library and obviously people all
over the world are in admiration of the
ukrainian people as they continue their
fight here it's amazing you know music
can be so healing and so inspiring for
him to be able to do that and and trying
to think of his his family and friends
well on the stage he was trying to make
a speech and he had to stop i imagine
because then he had to go on and just
talk about the music wow so it's a
beautiful thing and hopefully more
people will be able to find support